hello everyone i am ruthvi and i
did this internship with pine biotech
and i worked on the topic of multiple
sclerosis
i was very fascinated by this topic and
the kind of different characteristics it
shows like
lesions and everything will look ahead
of so the reason for choosing this topic
was this one
so i'm an undergraduate third year
student of biomedical sciences and i'm
from
india gujarat my interest particularly
on neuroscience cancer neurobiology and
bioinformatics precisely
neuroinformatics
i've worked on dipg multiple sclerosis
for this project and autism and
immunology
so before diving it into the project i
would like to brief you all about what
actually multiple sclerosis is
so it is a central nervous system
disorder
mainly a white matter diseases which is
a neurodegenerative diseases
and characterized and it is
characterized by
the demyelination of the myelin sheath
in the axons
because of demyelination the patients of
multiple sclerosis suffer
an acute episode of neurological
disturbances
and also due to this demyelination the
balance between the brain and the body
that is the normal rhythm also gets
disrupted
so usually multiple sclerosis
till now has been regarded as a white
matter diseases but since last
five years there has been extensive
research that shows that
not only white matter but multiple
sclerosis also affects the gray matter
still the underlying causes of it have
to yet to be unfolded
so talking about the morphology of
multiple sclerosis
the pathology is characterized by the
multiple focal lesions
and the ms flakes that develops in white
matter as well as gray matter
areas of the cortical regions of the
brain so till now scientists have found
out that t
cells that is activated t cells in the
lymph nodes
enter the cns through blood brain
barrier and then they start attacking
the
myelin sheath of the exon due to which
demyelination
happens but in the first place there has
been no research till date which shows
that
why these t cells or say b cells get
activated and attack
the myelin sheath so talking about my
research question and hypothesis
so my main research question was that
patients
of multiple sclerosis have
less or deemed cognitive functions and
they usually
tend to forget things and cannot pay
attention to any particular thing
so memory loss is one of the most
important characteristics of
ms also so using this main research
question i wanted to answer my
hypotheses that were three divided as
first
i wanted to know the biological pathways
and their respective functions that were
affected in patients
that had gray matter lesions that is ms
patients
i also wanted to find out that does
multiple sclerosis precisely have
effect over the development or
differentiation of protein cells
because you will see a health that i had
gene ontology results presenting
hematopoietic stem cell lineage pathways
as well and i also wanted to know that
are there any specific genes in multiple
sclerotic lesions that they are
upregulated or down regulated and any
specific
role with any biological pathway that
they play or not in multiple sclerosis
so owing to this hypothesis i started my
i started searching my data set so this
was the data set that i found
and it consists of tissue samples of
cortical tissues
and it had total 184 samples in totals
out of which this is a super series so i
took only one sub series
that had 78 samples which had gray
matter lesions versus control gray
matter
so this is a slide depicting my
study methodology so firstly what i did
was rna sequencing analysis
so i had three types of uh sub data
sets like the sub data experimental
groups
the first one was the gray matter
lesions the second one was normal
appearing gray matter and the third were
controls
so firstly i wanted to explore all the
conditions by comparing it them with
each other so first i did my exploratory
analysis
in which i compared all the three of the
groups with each other by doing a t-test
under all conditions that is all three
later on i compared each
two of them with each other that is
lesions with normal appearing gray
matter
by normal appearing gray matter i mean
that that person
has multiple sclerosis but do not have
lesions
so i compared lesions with normal
appearing gray matter by bca
and also compared controls with normal
appearing gray matter
the variation i saw was good in both but
the most variation i could see was among
control and gray matter lesions which we
will see
further so i downstream my analysis
and then went for comparative analysis
between gray matter lesions and control
gramata
for differential gene expression i used
edge r
and after getting up and down regulated
and significant genes
i did gene selection with a top 700
genes that i got
and further on i did pathway analysis
again i did visualization by pca
and then heat map for all the
significant genes that i had
extracted out and later on when i got my
results i did literature review in order
to compare my
results with previous studies and get
conclusions
and derive conclusions from them so
talking about my exploratory analysis so
this was the first pc i did
on my left hand side you can see the pca
between
normal appearing gray matter and gray
matter lesions and on the right hand
side you can
see controls and grey metal lesions so
you can see that the
after downstreaming my analysis the
variation
among this that is healthy and gray
metallization was very well so i took
forward
my downstream analysis with this part of
the data set
this is a slide depicting the heat map
with significant genes
so i had selected significant genes with
p value less than or equal to
0.05 so in this heat map it can be
clearly seen that most of the
significant genes
are down regulated in the lesions
whereas
adam regulated in the control samples
whereas most of them are upregulated in
grey matter lesions which showed a clear
indication that in lesions something is
upregulated which
leads the formation of inflammation
or rather say lesions so
after selecting upregulated and
downregulated genes and my significant
genes i did pathway analysis using the
human gauge
pipeline on t bioinfo server so the top
two heat pathways that i got was first
is olfactory transduction pathway and
second i got was hematopoietic stem cell
lineage pathway
so for olfactory transduction pathway
the
r1 you can see over here that is the oil
factory receptor r protein which is
responsible for sensing the odor and
smell detectant pathways
was highly upregulated was highly
upregulated in gray matter lesions
so i'm sorry down regulated in gray
matter lesions due to which it was
a possible association that people who
are detected with multiple sclerosis
have a lowered sense of smelling and
odor detection
the second pathway that i got was
hematopoietic stem cell lineages
and it could be seen that among the
whole picture of this pathway
interleukin-3 is highly downregulated so
over here a source association can be
made that
is down regulation of interleukin-3 a
possible reason for t cells attacking
the myelin sheath
or under developed bone marrow a
possible cause of multiple sclerosis
onset
so after this pathway analysis i did the
pathway analysis with enricher with
particular down regulated genes
so in down regulated genes you can see
that the top hits were all olfactory
receptor activities and
perception of smell pathways which
clearly indicated that this pathway was
disturbed in the
patients of multiple sclerosis further i
did pathway analysis with upregulated
genes which showed top hit
in ribosomal protein synthesis and
oxidative phosphorylation
which were also the results i got on
human gauge t
bio info platform server pipeline
so after that i had to make associations
so the possible association i could make
was the down regulation of
olfactory receptor proteins and multiple
sclerosis
so what i did was out of the significant
genes expressed i picked out the genes
which were responsible for
the oil faction that is or genes and i
plotted a bulk plot comparing it with
gml lesions
and controlled gray matter so in the bad
plot it is quite evident
that in lesions these genes are down
regulated
and as compared to the control so these
were the top 12 genes
again this was my hypothesis so i needed
my
validation to be concluded in order to
prove that my findings
are true which would come ahead in the
next slides
so after that i also found that protein
kinase a
which was severally related to my
studies so protein kinase a generally
functions in cognitive functioning like
inactivation of brain reward system
or in preservance of short-term and
long-term memory so as per our keg
analysis
pka protein in the order detection
pathway
is highly down regulated in multiple
sclerosis patients which had lesions
so we can also make a possible
association i
i'm not saying that i'm quite sure but
over here i'm talking about an
association
between pka and the loss of cognitive
functions or
the memory loss in patients of multiple
sclerosis
because over here in the picture it is
quite clearly visible that
protein sinus a is present in nucleus
acumens
and protein kinase a is directly
activated by dopamine receptors which
are responsible for producing dopamine
a loss of dopamine is also an important
characteristics in patients of multiple
sclerosis and hence a possible relation
can be made between
pka protein and memory loss and multiple
sclerosis
moving to the analysis of hematopoietic
stem cell lineage pathways there were
three or four possible questions
and associations i could possibly make
so still more research is needed in
future to assess the precise effects of
multiple sclerosis on differentiation of
protein cells
but however down regulation of
interleukin in the whole hematopoietic
stem cell lineage pathway shows that
thrombocytopenia
which are often the main characteristics
of patients of ms
so talking about the hypothesis that is
the top 12 olfactory genes that we found
that were down regulated in gml patients
that is
ms patients i took another data set that
106 samples
so 106 samples were divided into
cortical normal appearing gray matter
versus control gray matter
so again this was a brain cortical
tissue gray matter tissue
sample of and i use this is a different
data set and i use this for validation
so to my excitement for the validation
there were also other olfactory genes
that were down regulated by
but i extracted the 12 genes that were
there in my hypothesis and compared it
to the controls
and in validation i exactly got the same
results that is these genes were
as well down regulated in multiple
sclerosis patients
without lesions as well so hence
it was pretty sure that olfactory
dysfunction
and oil factory disruption pathway is
seen in patients of multiple sclerosis
also for a better picture i have plotted
a box plot representing the down
regulation of
genes in normal appearing gray matter
the olfactory genes
and they are normally expressed in
healthy controls
so my key findings and suggestions
include the top 12
olfactory genes which were shown to be
down regulated in multiple sclerotic
patients
a possible association between protein
kindness a
cognitive loss of functions and compared
to multiple sclerosis
also as for from our keg analysis a
possible association can be made between
suppressed production of interleukin-3
and thrombocytopenia and multiple
sclerosis
for my future directions i would state
that much research is needed in this
area to assess the precise effect of
multiple sclerosis
and protein cells differentiation and
development
also more comprehensive research is
needed to support my findings
and i am done with my presentation thank
you so much
thank you so much rothwe for sharing
with us your research work and it's
really great
now i would want our mentors to please
provide the reviews and the suggestions
to ruthie
i mean i just want to say that rudy it's
very exciting to see your
uh presentation uh kind of coming
together
if you could please go back to your
first slide just so that we have
something
in front of us so i think that
you know it's very interesting how you
went through this
project and kind of developed your
hypothesis
to then finding the specific signal
then focusing on validation and
you ended up with multiple questions at
the end that i think
do require further research so i really
like the way that you structure
the presentation and i'm hoping that you
know as you move forward i know that you
still have some time left
that you will find an opportunity to
collaborate with
other people on addressing some of these
questions perhaps or if you have some
you know kind of
further questions that appear that you
would like to focus on
so could you speak a little bit about
how
this process worked for you you know how
long did it take
when did you kind of clearly identify
that specific question that you had in
mind
like what was that like for you okay so
to be honest i started in middle fair
brewery
and i am a biomedical sciences student
with a zero experience in bioinformatics
and i'm not at all ashamed to say this
that i did not
even know that what nc by ncbi stands
for
or is there even a website named ncbi
so firstly i had to do all these courses
and after doing courses i didn't even
know what data sets meant
so i had to had few sessions with herpet
ma'am
so she taught me about how to find a
data set how to extract that so
everything and finding a correct data
set took me
two months to be honest finding it on my
own
but after that doing pca differential
gene expression i obviously had
technological
and technical problems as well but you
know when you learn
on your own after doing a thing you text
your
teachers and they give you a time but
you cannot wait in between for the
specific
amount of time so you start reviewing
articles or searching on
youtube the videos that the institution
has uploaded in order to solve your
query on your own
so one thing i learned in this project
is to overcome difficulties
on our own and then going to the mentors
because
mentors have really an expertise way of
selling them and after talking to my
mentors everything seemed
so easy i i remember in february there
was a time when i didn't know anything
and i had to
you know exactly ask my mentors what
should i do what is pc and everything
but after four months now i am helping
my fellow colleagues and
the persons who are working with me so
it has been an incredible curvy journey
but i have definitely learned
a lot from this
all right great thank you very much i
think that's a great perspective so
thank you for sharing again i know it's
been a long journey and
really excited to see the results sure
thank you